good morning so I'm gonna try and give
as much of a whirlwind tour of the
entire field with the introduction as I
can in the time available we're gonna
have to skim a little bit but that's
that's fun okay so first up I after I
submitted the talk came to learn that
our bluffers guides are not miss surfs
necessarily as common a term in North
America as they are from England and New
Zealand where I'm from so just so
everyone knows what they mean
I think Cole's notes but for any topic
so it's really meant to be a sort of a
light-hearted humor a survey of a topic
to just give you an overview of the
whole subject all right so that means
the focus of this talk is really on the
core intuitions and core ideas rather
than the nitty gritty details of exactly
how these algorithms work I want you to
come away with an understanding of
dimension reduction broadly and sort of
how you can think about it rather than
necessarily particular details of how
any given technique works so that means
I'm going to introduce a little bit of
extra notation which is gonna be really
useful repeatedly and that's the red
star so sometimes technical details
really really matter but they're not
worth getting into because by the time
you've explained all the technical
details you have lost the point of what
you are trying to explain in the first
place
so if I just want the big picture idea
and there are some technical details
that make that statement not technically
true but morally it's the right thing
I'm just gonna put a red star by it so
it's essentially true but you know
there's lots of technical details that
make it not exactly true okay so first
of all there are only two dimensional
reduction techniques so in practice that
means really there's either matrix
factorization or neighbor graphs and
that's pretty much all there is other
than feature selection techniques and
one special case that I'll mention in
the minute so matrix factorization
really means this huge broad class of
techniques it's everything from topic
modeling to word embeddings plain old
PCA all kinds of other probabilistic
techniques it covers a huge swath of
algorithms but I could
all be thought of under a sort of very
simple basic single matrix factorization
framework and so in the end what really
matters is what matrix you construct a
factor and how you compute the sort of
reconstruction error of your
factorization and what constraints you
put on that optimization you work those
out and that will give you these
different sorts of algorithms neighbor
graphs is again a very broad class of
techniques this is everything from
spectral embedding to tyranny to large
va's you map falls in this category as
well these are all basically built
around an idea that you're gonna build a
graph out of your data and then you're
gonna embed that graph in a low
dimensional space and at the end of the
day that's all you're really doing all
the detail comes in to how you construct
the graph how you layout that graph so
the the odd one out here that I
mentioned is autoencoders little linear
auto-encoders fit nicely in matrix
factorization but the auto encoders are
a very broad class of things and various
families of auto-encoders are not gonna
be phrased as matrix factorization at
the end of the day so they're kind of an
odd one out but I'm gonna push that
aside because I really want to just
focus on the fact that you only really
need to know two things to know all
there is to know about dimension
reduction so let's start with matrix
factorization so first we'll look at
what it is and then walk through a
number of examples covering a bunch of
different algorithms and sort of give
you an idea of how you can specialize it
into all these different specialized
algorithms that exist and give you some
idea of the scope of algorithms that you
can actually build out of there's a very
simple idea of just factoring a matrix
okay so the goal of matrix factorization
pictorially is we want to express a
matrix as approximately a product of two
smaller matrices that's all we're doing
so in terms of dimension reduction the
blue matrix is their data that's the the
the source data we've got in sort of
each row is a sample each column is a
feature and we want to sort of factor
that into a representation multiplied by
some archetypes so you can think of the
representation that's your low
dimensional representation the
archetypes are sort of the basic
forms the exemplars that you're going to
use to reconstruct the original data so
looking just at a single row you can
think of a single row of your data a
single sample as being represented as
one row of your representation there's a
corresponding representation for each
sample and it's going to be multiplied
by or act on the entire matrix of
archetypes so breaking that out what
you're actually getting is a single rode
expressed as a linear combination of
these archetypes and the coefficients of
that linear combination are your
representation you're a low dimensional
representation so that's all we're
really doing we're we're expressing our
data as a combination of these
archetypes and that's matrix
factorization now math makes this pretty
because I just get to write this instead
of complicated pictures but as matrices
this is our data X is approximately
equal to u times V now the upside of
math is that this makes it all nice and
compact the key here is that that
approximately equal to that's going to
be pretty much everything that goes on
in these algorithms how do we define
approximately equal to depending on how
you define it you can get lots of
different things so what we can do is
turn this into a different problem turn
it into an optimization problem what
what approximately equal to is going to
me is we're going to try and minimize
some notion of error or a loss so we can
define it this way we're trying to
minimize this loss between our original
data and our reconstructed data subject
to some constraints and exactly how we
define that loss and what those
constraints are are going to give us all
these different matrix factorization
techniques now if you're interested in
this mentality of thinking about things
I highly recommend you go and read the
generalized low ranked models paper by
who dealt at all it's a fabulous paper
it's hideously long but don't be
intimidated it's actually really easy
reading it's well written very easy to
follow and it gives you a really broad
understanding of how general matrix
factorization can work ok so let's go
through some examples let's start with
principle component analysis because
it's sort of the standard
four dimensional reduction using these
sorts of techniques and really what that
means is that it turns out that just
mean squared error can do a lot for you
especially if you get around to playing
with the constraints so classical PCA is
just taking that loss and writing the
loss as the squared error between each
of the terms we're just gonna sum it up
over all the entries so that is PCA now
in practice PCA is computed by fancy
linear algebra techniques but this is
what it's computing so you can think of
it in these terms this is your loss
you're just talking about the squared
error one of the problems PCA can run
into is that it's it's sometimes hard to
interpret especially if you have a load
your low dimensional representation has
a lot of dimensions you're reducing to
maybe 20 50 dimensions that's a lot of
different archetypes you're combining if
you're trying to think of it as a linear
combination of archetypes and so it's
sometimes hard to wrap your head around
oh well I have you know 0.13 of this
feature archetype and 0.78 of that one
and it gets very complicated to think
about so you can constrain your
optimization so that you're only going
to have so many archetypes in each
representation actually showing up so
that's as simple as adding constraints
to our optimization so if we add some
constraints we actually get a whole
brand new technique called sparse PCA
which is entirely different
except it's not you're just adding some
constraints and so what we're going to
constrain is the number of nonzero
entries in air representation you each
row of U is only allowed to have K many
nonzero entries so that's going to make
it much more interpretable because I'm
going to be able to say yeah I mean it's
got a linear combination of these
archetypes but any given representation
is at most K many archetypes and you can
make K a lot smaller than that I mention
you're reducing to that it makes it much
more interpretable easier to understand
what's going on okay fewer archetypes
was good let's turn the dial to 11 and
yep constrain it as much as possible
what if I see it I only want one
archetype to appear per row
did we actually get k-means clustering
so this gives you some idea of how
general this sort of framework is we've
just managed to go from PCA to
k-means clustering by just turning a
dial on how I do my constraints so in
practice what I'm going to get is a
matrix U which has one nonzero entry in
each row the index in that row is going
to be the cluster label and the
archetypes are literally the cluster
centroids from k-means now this is not
how you're going to compute k-means but
this is the result you're going to head
toward alright let's try some different
algorithms non-negative matrix
factorization so especially in the case
when your data is all positive it can be
kind of hard to think about subtracting
components off PCA allows the
coefficients to be positive or negative
and it's easy to think about composing
the archetypes together I'm adding this
and then it's a the addition of this and
the addition of that but then if I'm
subtracting away things that's that's
harder for people to wrap their brains
around so if you want to make an
interpretable thing that's easier to
present to other people it's purely an
additive composition of the archetypes
it's a lot easier to think about and
that's all don- matrix factorization is
doing its pca but I'm just going to
constrain my U and V matrices to only
have positive entries I'm just taking
constraints on PCA that's all it is and
this is non-negative matrix
factorization again or the details of
how to compute this are a different
matter but this is what it's doing now
most non-negative matrix factorization
also have a KL loss to option which
looks something like this which looks
really weird but we'll come back to that
after a head look at exponential family
PCA in a minute and this will make a lot
more sense as well as why the
constraints work out quite as well as
they do so let's let's move straight an
exponential family PCA is kind of a
fancy way of generalizing all of this
with a bunch of probability theory so
the goal here is what if I knew more
about my data well if I had some sort of
model for how my data was generated
suppose my
data each entry was a count of something
for each feature I've got counts if I
ask a statistician she'll tell me that I
should probably model that with a
Poisson model so can I incorporate their
extra information into my matrix
factorization so here the goal is to
look at theta which is going to be my my
product of U times V G my reconstruction
not as a reconstruction of X but it's a
reconstruction of model parameters that
will make X the most likely thing to see
so the loss term is now going to be the
negative log likelihood of observing my
data under this model that I'm
reconstructing so I want a low-rank
model that makes my data as likely as
possible so how do we parameterize that
well the easy way to go is the
exponential family of distributions it's
a nice easy to parameterize entire
family of distributions that covers all
your favorites like normal distributions
plus on gamma Jewish labor and only the
lot so there's a nice big family and
it's easy to work with because the
negative log likelihood is proportional
to this where this G function of the
theta parameters is really just
something you can look up for each
individual different distribution and
plug in to your loss so let's test this
out and see if this is actually going to
give us anything meaningful
so what if I told my stats frame that my
data was normally distributed they're
going to tell me to use normal matrix
factorization where normal is my
probabilistic term there so for the
normal distribution G is just half of
the l2 norm of the rows so it's half the
reconstruction u times V squared and I'm
gonna have no constraints as paranormal
okay
that doesn't look like anything that I
would understand very easily but I can
do this because the X IJ are my data
they're never changing those are
constant so I can add on X IJ terms and
it won't change the minimization I'm
doing so I can add on this half X IJ
squared term and that doesn't change the
minimization or the
objective that I'm effectively computing
there okay that looks weird but what am
i doing well if I complete the square
then magically it turns out that normal
matrix factorization is PCA or in other
words PCA is just what you would do if
you assume your data is normally
distributed this should give you a warm
fuzzy feeling that this is actually
working entirely as we expect because
normal distributions are probably what
you might want to guess if you know
nothing else okay so that's great but
let's go back to count data what if I
what if I had count data and I wanted to
use Poisson distributions what does
Poisson matrix factorization look like
well for possible matrix factorization
the G is just the exponential function
so you get out a loss function that
looks like this and now you should think
back to the KL loss for the non-negative
matrix factorization and realize that
this looks almost the same except we
swapped an exponent the catch here is
that now I have no constraints with
non-negative matrix factorization
I had constraints on my U and V so that
everything came out positive that's
basically saying the lambda parameter
for a plus all should be a positive
number the arrival rate should be
positive if Yuri parameterize your Lamb
your thoughts on distributions with log
lambda instead then you get this and now
I can do the whole thing with no
constraints which makes for a much
cleaner easier optimization to run we
lost some of the interpretability issues
with non-negative matrix factorization
but we gained a much easier optimization
problem out of it and you can play this
game with anything by know mu my tricks
factorization Bernoulli matrix
factorization beta matrix factorization
pick your favorite distribution that you
think describes your data well you can
plug it into the formula work out what
you should get as your loss function and
magically you have yet another matrix
factorization algorithm that is
dimensional reductions specialized to
your type of data so this is a really
powerful technique okay what about
latent dirichlet allocation this is not
to be introduction this is like topic
modeling with like crazy Bayesian
graphical models that are complicated
well let's work through it what if my
theta parameters were multinomial
distribution so each row of my
reconstructed matrix is parameters for a
multinomial distribution okay I can work
out what multinomial matrix
factorization looks like now I've
alighted some there but you can you can
push this through and this is pretty
much what you get out this is what
multinomial matrix factorization will
look like the last term just follows
through from that negative log
likelihood and I'm gonna have to stick
some constraints on my reconstruction so
so that my U times V actually give me
things that look like parameters of a
multinomial distribution that's great
but we can we can go a little bitter we
can we can add a latent variable okay so
the goal here is that if I make you my
matrix U a multinomial over this K and
then my V is provides K as a multinomial
over my features then when I multiply
these two things together magically I
get out the result being parameters for
a multinomial distribution so where
previously here I had these odd
parameters on U times V I can swap that
for parameter for constraints on you and
constraints on V separately that will
guarantee I get the right constraints on
my multiplied together thing but we get
more we get actually some quite nice
interpretability out of this because now
each row of U air representation is
going to be a multinomial distribution
over archetypes so I can interpret a row
of my u in other words a point in my low
dimensional representation as a
distribution over archetypes and each
archetype is going to be a distribution
over my features so this is nice its
interpretive we can understand what it's
doing stick all that in and we get
probabilistic latent semantic indexing
which looks just the same I just changed
my constraints a little okay that's
great and powerful and it has all that
interpretability
victors of probabilities of archetypes
in each archetype is
a victor of probabilities of features
that's pretty cool but we can be even
more hip and trendy let's be Bayesian
and we can apply it directly prior over
the multinomial distributions for U and
V and just take a step back okay
and that's L da that's all L da is now
there's a lot of details I carefully
stripped down to the rug but this is all
you need to do to understand basically
the mechanics of what's going on in LD a
it's a matrix factorization in a
probabilistic sense where I'm just
thinking of everything in terms of
multinomial distributions that's why it
works so well on we're if you take a bag
of words view of a document
I've just got counts of words appearing
well a document is a count of the all
the different words counts of words
appearing in the document that's a
multinomial distribution this is
entirely the right way to model this so
if you can come up with a model for your
data you can use matrix factorization
techniques to do all kinds of
surprisingly fancy things that really
are just matrix factorization under the
hood so this should give you some idea
of how incredibly powerful matrix
factorization can be we started with
something as simple as PCA and we've
ended up with really quite sophisticated
techniques that can do quite powerful
things but it's all still the same basic
idea under the hood and it's pretty easy
to understand when you think of it in
those terms
okay how about neighbor graphs so
neighbor graphs cover a wide range of
algorithms some of them build graphs
with edges between all the points even
so neighbor graphs is perhaps not the
best term but it's the best term I could
come up with and the catch here is that
the resulting algorithms are a lot more
diverse than matrix factorization matrix
factorization there was sort of a
consistent story
I could write everything in the same
terms neighbor graphs things look very
different but there are some really core
common themes at the end of the day
which is that you need some way to build
a graph and you need some way to embed
that graph so let's have a look at some
of the intuition behind this so here's
some data and there's some low
dimensional structure in that data that
you can hopefully see but a linear
approach like PCA is not going to find
it but if I draw
a graph where I linked each point with
an edge if it's in the K nearest
neighbors of that point
magically this graph seems to have
uncovered that structure that I wanted
to find so that's the intuition for
these sort of neighbor graph type
approaches and one can be either more or
less formal about how you go about
describing this you can either hark to
this intuition or you can go and use
fancy topology to say that no no this is
actually mathematically doing the right
thing but this is the guts of what's
going on now one caveat and the reason
there's a red star on both these
pictures is that this is the intuition
of what's going on but this picture is
really deceptive because it's convenient
in 3d where you can see what's going on
and get an intuition that does not scale
to higher dimensions and the sort of
weirder structures you can get in your
data in higher dimensions and so while
this gives you an idea of what's going
on the intuitions you get don't
necessarily work out as well as you'd
like for actual real data okay so the
questions you need to ask are how do I
build the graph and how do i weight the
edges of that graph if you can work that
out and we'll get you a long way through
the algorithm and we'll look through
several different algorithms in a minute
and then how do I lay out that graph and
low dimensions there's lots of ways of
going about that we'll go through a few
as we look through some of the different
algorithms here so I assume app is one
of the early approaches to this sort of
neighbor graph style approach to the
problem so here we're going to take the
K nearest neighbors and we're going to
weight them by the ambient distance in
the high dimensional space we work in so
assuming we're in Euclidean space I'm
just going to put a weight on each edge
which is the Euclidean distance between
the points and now I'm gonna build a
complete graph that needs a graph with
edges between all possible points
weighted by the shortest path links on
that graph that I had so in in pictures
I have I have one red point I have
another red point I want to say how far
apart of these red points what's the
weight I want to give it to the edge
between these two red points
and it's going to be the puffs the
length of the path through the graph
that gets me there in the shortest route
that's it and then we're gonna build an
adjacency matrix out of the graph and
adjacency matrix matrices aren't
anything fancy they're just the weight
of the edge or zero if there's no edge
and that's good so now we have a matrix
so how do we turn a matrix into a low
dimensional representation you should
know this by now we factor the matrix
that's exactly what they do they just
take the largest eigen vectors okay so
what about spectral meaning they have a
different approach to weighting the
edges they gotta take a kernel over each
point and white edges according to that
kernel so the further away points are
the lower the white I'm going to apply
to them now this has a nice feature
because you noticed that adjacency
matrix representation I had zero if I
had no edge but I had a really big
number if points were really far apart
it would be nice if I didn't have to
have all the edges filled in I could
just have edges that are really far
apart having a very small number that's
close to zero so smooth everything out
and everything works better so this is
the the idea behind this you're going to
build a kernel over each the edges some
sort of like Gaussian RBF type kernel
and work with that and then we're gonna
compute this thing called the graph
laplacian which is a complicated formula
there's a bunch of them but what you can
think of it as I have these weights
attached to each edge and I basically
want to divide out by the marginals of
either the rows and the columns so that
I sort of normalize things out that's
really what's going on there
and then we have a matrix again so we
factor the matrix this time we're going
to take the smallest eigen vectors
because we swapped everything around we
were had small numbers and still large
ones there's a red star there there's
one of the eigenvectors you actually
ignore but that's okay
all right tsnhe distributed as a
stochastic neighbor invading which is
often described in in probabilistic
theory terms but it's really a graph
algorithm as well at the end of the day
so
with spectral and meeting we used a
single bandwidth for the kernel
everywhere across all the data with
t-sne we're gonna vary the bandwidth
vary how wide I'm gonna make that kernel
according to the density of the data
essentially now there's some complicated
formulas for how exactly one does that
but that's that's not really what you
need to sort of worry about mostly we're
just going to take the K nearest
neighbors and we're gonna vary the size
of the kernel to match roughly with
those K neighbors then I'm gonna
normalize outgoing edges so that all the
outgoing edge weights sum for one that's
just a thing I'm gonna do and then I'm
gonna symmetrize the whole thing so that
I'm gonna if I have two edges with
different weights between two points I'm
just gonna average them and then I'm
gonna renormalize the whole thing so
that all the edge weights in the whole
graph sum to 1 ok that's a complicated
bunch of manipulations and it's not
exactly obvious from my description why
anyone would want to do them
there are justifications for all of this
they're in the TS any paper is your more
than welcome to read through it but what
I want you to take away from this is
that exactly how to weight the edges
matters t-sne works really well it works
well because it goes to a lot of trouble
to work out a good way to provide edge
weights that really work and so modern
techniques will jump through a lot of
Hoops and have a lot of complicated
operations to wait these edges in
certain ways to make the think the the
algorithm worked well ok so how do i
layout the graph well I use a force
directed layout this time so this is
actually a standard approach in laying
out graphs in network science or graph
practice as opposed to graph theory and
so what's going on here is I have a
graph and nodes have a repulsive force
between them
so is that showing yes ok so they're
gonna spread apart and edges have an
attractive force that are gonna pull
things together and that's all that's
gonna be going on I'm gonna push nodes
apart generally with a standard
repulsive force and I'm gonna pull nodes
together along edges with an attractive
force and how you compute those forces
are gonna change your exam
algorithm but you can think of it as
kind of the repulsive forces often
described as like an electric field
that's repulsive between the the points
and Springs for edges that pull
everything together see it's like a
spring algorithm and and that's that's
all you have to do you're gonna have
decaying forces so that the the further
apart nodes are the less repulsive force
there is between them and so on but at
its core you're pushing nodes apart in
general pulling them together along
edges and that's all you have to do so
here's this this is a the top graph and
if you use this algorithm standard force
directed layout type algorithm it sort
of pushes everything around pulls things
together along the edges and it's sort
of slowly but surely relaxes into a nice
layout and this is really old t-sne is
doing is this sort of force directed
layout has a particular way of computing
the the attractive and repulsive forces
but that's that's the specifics for the
core ideas all that's doing is this okay
so finally you met uniform manifold
approximation of projection how does it
work is it K neighbor algorithm yes yes
it is really we just take the K nearest
neighbors weighted according to a bunch
of fancy math and it turns out that it's
not very elucidating without a whole lot
of background to describe what those
manipulations are t-sne was bad enough
to describe the manipulations this won't
help much but you can look up my talk
from Sify this year if you want more
details on how this is actually computed
and the intuitions behind why you would
go through the crazy manipulations we
have but this is the general idea the
core of it is that at the end of the day
it's kind of similar to t-sne but we're
gonna derive a different kernel by a
different math with different approaches
and then we're just going to use a force
directed light out now we're gonna again
different math wind into it so we're
going to derive different forces so the
force directed layout is going to be a
little different
but fundamentally we're just still doing
the same force-directed layout of a
graph and that's that's the core idea
behind you man okay so in summary
dimension reduction is really built on
just a couple of premises matrix
factorization neighbor graphs that's
really everything to it and framing a
problem as a matrix factorization or a
neighbor neighbor graph algorithm
captures most of the core intuitions of
those algorithms so this is sort of a
general framework for understanding most
dimension reduction algorithms if you
come across a new algorithm and you want
to try and understand it what you want
to do is ask yourself can i frame this
as a matrix factorization problem is
this really just building a neighbor
graph in some complicated way that they
hid in their description of it and if so
what matrix are they factoring how are
they what's their loss function what are
their constraints or what graph are they
building and how are they laying it out
if you can work through those aspects of
it you can actually understand almost
any dimension reduction technique pretty
quickly at least at an intuitive level
for what's really going on so this is a
great way to understand dimension
reduction in general all right questions
we need yeah we probably don't have
enough time for this but I mean you
clearly are very short on details for
you know you map is there any way you
could explain like the the basic you
know intuition like or give some some
you know references or you know some
some suggestions for understanding the
basic intuition behind these things like
like even for t-sne
like it's a little unclear to me like
you know so you describe the scheme but
like what is the intuition behind this
scheme like I feel like I have no
understanding of why that's a good thing
that's that's a fair question and I
won't speak to the intuitions behind
t-sne because they they write it in
certain terms and I'm I'm less
comfortable describing their intuitions
I can understand some of the intuitions
for you map so one of the core things
that went on there was we had this
variable size kernel why would you want
to do that is a perfectly good question
and so for you map the answer to that
question is that ultimately these
neighbor graph algorithms are based on
topological techniques the graphs are
really a topological thing and those
topological techniques only work if the
data happens to be uniformly distributed
on a manifold and your data probably
isn't at least with respect to the
ambient space that the data lies in by
varying the size of the kernel
we're basically adapting the metric on
the manifold to make that be true and so
that's the sort of part of the magic
sauce that makes all of this work the
catch with doing that is that we now
made everything incompatible all these
different patches have a different
notion of distance and we have to
somehow glue all that back together and
that's where that
lining t-sne just average things but
there are different ways to think about
how to do that and so you want to glue
all that back together so that's how
your your operations for building the
graph are it's the same core intuition
that went into spectral and bidding
where I put a kernel over things that I
want similarities between things but I'm
adapting it to deal with the fact that
there's these topological obstructions
to this algorithm actually working how
do I work around those how do I get the
algorithm to make it work in this more
general case is that okay thank you so
much for this talk and all of the effort
to really kind of paint some some big
picture and and like relationships
between things have you thought about
what relationships exist from a
perspective of computational complexity
and the ability to do implement these
and in distributed and/or parallel
fashion so I'm really a mathematician so
I actually like to think in terms of
purely abstract stuff and not in terms
of implementation details although those
do come up and one catch is that these
are all wildly different and
computational complexity all those
wonderful matrix factorization
algorithms PCA is trivial to compute
relatively speaking because you can
solve that objective function in a
closed form with linear algebra like
that there's like here's here's what you
need to compute just do this linear
algebra operation whereas when I start
sticking some of those constraints on
now I just have an optimization problem
it's if I do some of the probabilistic
ones it's not necessarily even a nice
convex optimization problem and I've
just got to compute a whole lot of stuff
and try and optimize this and now it's
really hard so that is one of the
catches is the computational complexity
of these in no way matches the sort of
easy way you can tie them together in
terms of the underlying theory and
that's often why there are so many
different techniques is people want to
take different shortcuts to how to solve
the computational complexity issues
introduced by taking a different idea
Thanks
I really like the way that you made all
the matrix factorization techniques feel
the same in the same yoga that went into
solving those problems as optimization
problems and so I think there's a kind
of obvious question lurking in the
neighbor graph situation so we're gonna
eventually find ourselves the matrix
factorization problem but that first
step where we're picking different ways
of constructing the neighbor graph how
do we turn that into the same old
optimization problem to construct those
neighbor graphs because there are
different strategies to construct them
what's the what's the underlying
generalization I think that's a that's a
very astute question because I think
that's the research problem that is
going into these algorithms now is what
is the right way to think about this to
actually come up with a good clean
general theory that that you can adapt
and I don't think there are good answers
to that that is an open research problem
right now
I like the intuition you gave from you
map where it's like we're scaling the
these kernels to sit on the right metric
for the underlying table topology so I
don't know I got back of my mind
wondering obviously I think that's the
right way to go but
all right
Paul thank you Thanks